what's up believe nation today and when
I share with you my favorite top ten
rules to success April 2017 edition and
as always guys as people are talking if
you hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down accounts
below put quotes around it as well so
other people could be inspired and when
you're writing something down it's much
more likely to stick with yourself as
well enjoy the thing is every successful
person you know has failed at what they
love to do before
I've been unsuccessful in my career you
just didn't know about it because I
wasn't famous yet and I was trying to be
famous I was trying to get a record deal
for six years and I kept getting turned
down and any successful person you know
even though it seems like everything
just happened for them it usually was
preceded by a bunch of failure at least
a significant amount but the great ones
aren't the ones that don't fail they're
the ones that learn from their failure
and they keep going and persistently
tenacious and for me I was trying to get
a record deal for from 98 to 2004 and
got turned down by every major left a
record label including the one I'm
signed to now and for me that means that
even when you hear no you have to keep
going through all those knows and take
it to yes you know I grew up in Colombia
Colombia is a developing country where a
lot of people don't have access to the
most basic needs and where education is
considered a luxury unfortunately
because we all know that education is a
birthright and and I just grew up
frustrated seeing seeing how many people
weren't able to to realize their own
dreams you know when I was eight years
old my dad underwent an economic crisis
with financial crisis you know he lost
his business and we struggled
economically for many years we lost our
car we lost our furniture
and I remember vividly the day I walked
in my house and all the furniture was
gone because my head had my dad had to
pay his debt and it was quite well
shocking for me you know I was 8 6 7 8
years old and and when I saw this I was
so frustrated I my dad I felt sad with
my parents because I couldn't understand
how they did so poorly in business you
know I'm like why why you know I
couldn't I couldn't get it and my dad
and my mom took me to the part where
they showed me other kids my age
sniffing glue they were orphans
they had no one to watch after them and
they were barefoot and they were
abandoned to their own lot and it
probably left such an impression in my
impressionable mind at that age that I
remember that day and remember that I
made myself a promise I said I said to
myself Shakira you have to succeed
because you have to you have to ride in
a car again one day you know you have to
get your own car someday and and I
wanted to vindicate my parents socially
and economically and I also wanted to
someday do something for those kids - I
saw that day in the park so as soon as I
had my first big success with Pierre
discusss which was my third album I
decided to establish my own Foundation
and do my own contribution to to the
change even if it was going to be a
small one but I wanted to be active and
that's how it all started you know going
through my own financial struggle and
the struggle of my family and
understanding that the one thing that I
never lacked was care protection and in
education and that's probably what made
me thrive in life don't wait go do it
act now I'm really accepting we need you
we need you we need you you are the one
percent you're the percent that says I'm
going to wake up you are the light
workers you are the ones that have
accepted this call in this lifetime at
this time you have decided to wake up
and
chosen to say yes I'm here to be a
greater service and just to feed myself
right I'm here to feed the world I'm
here to give love I'm here to be an
expression of that truth don't hold that
back
don't play small we can't we need you
and so really if you are anyone in this
room who has been sitting on that book
idea waiting a little bit longer before
you start that teacher training or doing
ten more teacher trainings before you
actually teach if that's you guys start
and the pressure will be off I can't
begin to tell you I could cry to saying
this the mo the day I taught you
Eradicator I was two weeks into my
teacher training and I said f it let's
go and I just went and I felt so much
pressure off I felt so much lift because
I just knew I felt this technology must
be shared I can't hold it I can't keep
it for myself I can't just sit in my
apartment by myself like this I got to
give this and sharing it the pressure
this just lifted it was like oh thank
you thank you thank you and I wasn't the
perfect teacher and I look back and I
was teaching he's well-read occator
wrong everyone's arms were like this
everyone was breathing backwards it was
a mess but I did it and I started and in
those moments when we just get to go
just go the pressure is off and then we
clear the path and we are guided to the
next right action and that is the most
magnificent thing we could do right now
your habits determine what direction
you're going your success in life your
results in life are in direct proportion
to your habits what D not what you say
you're going to do but what are you
going to do you've got to develop
successful habits and I believe that
starts with being a daily goal setter
and a daily goal hitter that you get a
you know too many people spend their
whole life they say they're dreaming but
they're really just pipe dreams they're
thinking about what they want to be do
in 20 years and what their plans are way
out in the future let me tell you what
the future you need to be worried about
is not the next 20 years but the next 20
minutes what are you going to be doing
what are you going to be doing to be
effective when you get up every day know
your priorities life will overwhelm you
stuff will overwhelm you the with all
the information we have now whether it's
your phone where sometimes I think we
have smart phones and stupid people I
mean it is so easy to get consumed by a
bunch of stuff that is not going to get
you where you want to get to say every
day I will do today what others don't so
I will have tomorrow what others won't
you've got to choose to be effective
know what your priorities are know what
your must dues are don't let your phone
don't let your you know your tablet
don't let the TV don't let your friends
knock you off what are the most
important things to get done today Sir
Winston Churchill didn't have an inbox
he had an action this day box and so
things didn't get into that box that he
wasn't going to deal with that day so
may as John Wooden said make today your
masterpiece get up today and get it done
finish the day attack the day and go
change your life what you represent now
for all those kids out there trying to
make it whatever field it is whether
it's music or something else what words
do you have for them in terms of how you
live your life and you've made it to
this point because you're not supposed
to supposed to be here right now
now what advice you have for them in
terms of their lives in their journey
Lisa
well what does lace up mean for say it
you know it's the casual person it might
be seeing you for the first time on the
show
what is lace up I mean I mean it means
what you wanted to be but to me in a day
and age like this it means both feet on
that ground lace up and you're ready to
face the world go out there take it on
and and you know turn a grain of sand
into a diamond you know I'm telling ya I
think they love that answer right there
they're definitely laced and that's what
it's about man you know what it's about
it's about believing in something you
know what I'm saying like having faith
in something man like that's what it is
like we're not trying to hear some we're
not trying to hear some you know
president in a suit who you know can't
even live his own life and you know like
because he's so worried about public for
sighs we can't relate to that you know
I'm saying like they want to see someone
doing what they're doing living how
they're living coming from where they're
coming from and like making something
better of themselves and just sitting on
the rest you know I'm saying like that's
why that's why they're screaming they
like Dave because they they see that in
them and that's what I'm coming with on
the table one that's going to be the
People's Champ yeah you know I mean like
I don't I don't want to hear some
reverend tell me I have to believe in
organized religion I don't want to hear
some president suddenly is going to do
and not going to do because they never
do it I don't want to hear some teacher
put a limit on where my education can
take me you know I'm saying like they
want to teach me to you know go and fix
lights in the house but you don't want
to tell me that I can take my own career
into my own hands and be entrepreneur
and come up with something like this
they didn't teach you you could do this
yeah I'm just I'm just not I'm not
scared man I'm ready to step up and be a
leader for this generation of the
invoice for this generation and all
these people can act like to talk up for
these kids but it's just an act like I'm
still one of those kids man like this
means the world to me and that's that's
what this album is about
I just know I just know things are going
to change man it's I feel it I feel it I
believe in like I think if you if you
believe in what you're doing you know
many people tell you you know what why
your mistake and why it will never work
and you know but if you really believe
passionate what you're doing just just
stand and I keep going you know keep
keep pushing on keep pushing on and
until you either succeed or at least you
know you realize that you know it's just
it's just not going to happen and and
and then live it if you don't succeed
pick yourself up and and you know try
again and and ultimately you know if you
you know if you're that determined you
will succeed in life and then and if you
don't you haven't had a lot of fun
trying I was called the bull when on any
studio and nothing else matters where
the music you got this love for it's
something that you think about you sleep
and you dream and you wake up and you
breathing you want to live it there's so
many options there's many ways to blow
up as many ways to be known and forgets
and says that to be successful and it's
about picking that way to fit you I kept
going I had a path I knew what my path
was my path was to become what I am
right now now I lost sight of it in an
interesting sort of way or I I went
about it and wayward path but
fortunately for me all all the all the
getting hide the drinking the drugs and
everything else I did I showed up at the
theater every day I did plays ripped out
of my mind I rehearsed ripped out of my
mind but every lesson that I learned I
held on to for some reason God whatever
somebody let me hold on to everything
that I was learning my stage left on the
stage rights my upstage foot always out
turned down this way learning how to
develop a character doing all those
things because those are things that I
love and I did them in the midst of
everything else that I was doing - you
know when when my friends are getting
ready to go
more drugs not going to get to theater
and I kept y'all on the theater though
you know and I'm done and I said oh I
got to go build a set I got to do this
so I did everything that I had to do so
I was focused on this by any means
necessary plus I had a professor who was
like you know well you know all the
great ones do their jobs and ripped out
of their minds you know you look at the
bureau tools and uh yeah so they get
dropped make it hard they do what they
do but they show up and they do the job
so we were like okay and that's what we
did you know we drank with him and we
went to style vacuum class we've got
smoke joining come in and do our other
acting classes we'll go build a set on a
built-in costumes thanks like all the
things that we had to do so I kept
learning my lesson and doing them
sometimes a lot of people may try a new
initiative and then they don't get an
immediate reaction they and they think
it's a failure right I want to go to
your YouTube videos with the Wine
Library you know you had so much content
out there how did you stick in there how
did you keep yourself motivated because
I believe in my strategies and I'm
patient ish like all great stuff
especially when you're innovating
doesn't happen right away this notion
that like Oh Gary I tried it I spent
five hundred bucks on Facebook Ads it
doesn't work well what's your video
sucked what if your product and service
sucks I I tend to do things that are
very early that is been my career easy I
when I do things I believe in them I
stick with them based on intuition even
though for eighteen months nobody
watched my wine videos at all I knew it
was right I was right there's been
things I've done that I jumped off of
very quickly I started to Gary v app V
chat ve like we jabs are thes funny for
my fans great CRM one on one didn't feel
right after a week or two spend plenty
my building it knew it stopped it after
you know a couple months up why might be
TD five years every day YouTube decided
to change it to daily grape insular app
you could buy stuff subscription for
reviews it was a lot of fun only
difference five months stopped it
because they didn't feel right anymore
so it's always hard to know when to jump
off something new but I find that people
don't believe in what they're doing the
hero goo
you and they do it begrudgingly because
their boss wants them to or they're like
well Gary's right a lot so let me do it
but they you don't believe it
and so then they jump they're looking
for nose instead of yes is everything I
do every business development every
event I do every time I try new
marketing tactics or sales tactic I'm
looking for the yes right I'm looking
for the yes and if the no punches me
will then I like crap then no punched me
I believe the majority of people when
they try new tactics are looking for the
no and you're going to getting a lot of
subtle knows immediately right and so I
think that's why that happens your
success has been dramatic obviously and
coming from a city like Chennai of
course culturally very which we are in
in our own state of Tamil Nadu but more
importantly to be able to go global with
that has been just quite alms firing to
be honest and made all of us so proud
here in Chennai but if you look at young
musicians today and what they are being
offered and the technology it's moved
along as well what would you say to them
I think they have to find their own
voice if they found their own inner
voice in the moment we try to do
somebody else's they become a mediocre
moment we try our limitations are
sometimes our places so sometimes that
forces you to think in a way where there
many millions of ways to achieve a song
of achieve greatness in not so you find
a different way don't have to you know
if you a classic example as Kumar than
than others classical singer he had a
lung problem or something that so he
couldn't sustain his notes if you listen
to his rendering he would he would just
make everything shot he would lecture
you will never sustain it because of
breathing problem but that became a
great style don't have to copy that
because this limitation became a style
of what he could amazingly do and it was
unique when he said so
I think all of us have limitations and
we should not think it's a limitation so
there's something else which is there a
plus within you and then bring that out
and then you become totally
you are created by media for God you
were created to be meeting over you were
created for good works which he planned
beforehand you were created to do
amazing things and sometimes we just got
to realize our potential we got to
realize that we were created by house of
God your friends do amazing things and
sometimes we just have the confidence
that we were created to use something
special than building something special
but you have to believe in yourself you
have to believe that your gift is for
such a time as this you have to believe
that you have the power you have to
believe that you can make the choice
every single day to wake up to love it
and be passionate about it exactly right
thank you guys so much for watching I
love to know what did you think what was
your feedback lip what are you going to
take from this video and immediately
apply to your life or your business
somehow leave it down the comments below
I'm super curious to find out so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon